this video is sponsored by brilliant
explore Infinity AI logic puzzles and
everything else science and math through
the link in the description
you had no idea where you were or what
you were
you looked around it was white
everywhere as far as you could see
near you seemingly waiting for you was a
figure a vague translucent figure that
appeared to almost float as it moved
closer and closer toward you
you were not scared only unaware an
empty reservoir of pure consciousness
the term of your punishment has now
concluded the figure suddenly said to
you you had no memory of a punishment
you had no memory of anything at all
what punishment you asked the figure not
important right now the figure responded
you wouldn't understand yet anyway
what's important is what you choose to
do now
the figure moved even closer to you now
hovering next to your side you could
feel a light Breeze emanating off of
them they pointed forward and suddenly
the space in front of you began to
fragment and open up like it was an
invisible fabric being torn open on the
inside there was color and light
collections of particles and forms of
shapes and objects that appeared
familiar to you but that you couldn't
quite place what is that you asked the
figure
where you were the figure responded
inside the opening bodies of figures
began to walk by some stopped and talked
with each other too hugged their faces
began to cry
you approached the opening and looked
closer
you turn back to the figure
what did I have to do there
nothing the figure responded you were
free to do anything you wanted you look
back at the opening again the two people
were gone now the setting had changed
the figure gestured their hand at the
opening again sequences of scenes began
to go by each scene seemingly containing
the same figure
is that is that me you asked after
watching for a while
yes I don't understand what did I do who
was I
your name was Giannis you were a human
being you existed in a place with many
others like you all being punished for
more or less the same thing
there was a silence
then the figure continued
you were raised by your mother you were
extremely close with her you loved her
and she loved you more than anything she
taught you how to love how to be how to
become you made lots of friends
throughout your time you did all sorts
of things with them and had all sorts of
fun you experienced laughter and inside
jokes secrets and mutual care you had
relationships with beings you were
attracted to he fell in love multiple
times an unbelievable ecstasy and
excitement and comfort he got married to
a person named renetta your lives
intertwined becoming life Partners who
were there for each other for the rest
of each other's time
you had two kids you loved them like
your mother loved you and they loved you
like you loved your mother they provided
you with a sense of fulfillment and
purpose unlike anything else you
experienced you felt what it meant to
truly care about something
you developed interests skills and work
you work toward difficult achievements
and their difficulty made them worthy
when you finally achieved them you
became what you considered successful
you felt the corporeal Sensations and
Rich pleasures of having a body the
sense of individual autonomy and being
you tasted delicious foods you explore
beautiful places you experience novel
experiences as something somewhere
you discovered things and ideas you
pondered and marveled at the mystery of
where you were what you were you form
theories and beliefs you lived
you stared forward for a moment then you
said I don't understand how is that a
punishment that sounds amazing
the figure gestured their hand at the
opening again different but similar
scenes began to go by
well you began completely unaware hungry
and afraid your entire life you sought
safety stability understanding and
certainty at first your mother made
these conditions seem possible and real
but time ceaselessly move forward and
you aged and as you aged the world
around you grew bigger and more imposing
and your mother could no longer protect
you or provide you these things the
illusions of comfort and certainty
shattered and suddenly became your own
responsibility which you could never put
back together
throughout your time you lost your
friends one by one either from growing
apart in physical space or in personal
interests people you once trusted
completely who knew things about you
that no one else did who you spent all
your time with slowly became distant
strangers
some became enemies
every time you made new friends you
quietly feared the likely Prospect of
this happening again making it harder
and harder to connect with others the
same occurred with those you fell in
love with only the loss and separation
from them hurt far far worse beings you
saw your life with devoted your life to
who promised to always love you stopped
loving you some hated you all moved on
and replaced you
you told your friends and partners all
sorts of things that no one else ever
knew about you but no one ever really
understood you no matter how hard you
tried and how much you said and you knew
this
after you fell in love with renetta and
you decided you were ready to settle
down and commit to her you constantly
doubted your decision which only became
worse when the initial smoke of lust and
romance cleared and that spark of love
that had once ignited a fire within you
became a mere Ember that you always had
to attend to to keep lit the struggle to
sustain your relationship with your
children was not much different because
you could do anything the possibility
that you did the wrong thing always
loomed over and haunted you it was
difficult to get comfortable you were
always almost there almost in the right
position almost satisfied almost happy
but never quite you never knew exactly
what you were working toward but you
just kept working and doing you spent
most of your days in repetitive tedium
doing the same things over and over it
all exhausted you and it all went to
nothing but you had a strong hunch about
the whole time
you wanted to understand where you were
why things were the way they were but
delusions and truths appeared in equal
proportion you form beliefs but you knew
every belief was more like a hope a hope
that you could understand and that the
world around you could make sense but it
never did and it never could
eventually you watched your mother age
into an unrecognizable version of
herself that even she no longer
recognized she forgot who you were who
she was then you watched her die you
knew this was going to happen the whole
time you knew it was going to happen to
everyone including you
and it did
your friends your wife your children
you suffered you contracted diseases you
experienced the intense pain of having a
body and a mind
you clung to everything and lost it all
then you died
the figure gestured their hand at the
open portal again this time it closed
suddenly you felt a deep excruciating
sorrow it all came back to you
everything the pain and pleasure of an
entire lifetime all at once the meaning
and the absurdity of it all
I still don't understand you said what
was I being punished for
the figure stared back at you for a
moment then they said
desire passion judgment attachment for
seeing existence as a plurality of
objects separate from you and not a
single unification where you come from
where we come from we don't do that
you're quiet for a moment calm down the
figure said as they reached out and
grabbed you by the shoulder they
gestured their hand out again this time
two openings appeared in front of you
and one there was a bright warm light
with colors and fractals of blurred
vague objects reminiscent of your memory
and the other was Darkness with a light
mist and low hum emanating out of it
for the display of desire and passion
and attachment you have now seen and
experienced their pain and suffering but
your term is now complete you can step
out of the cycle of birth and rebirth
you can return to where you came from
where everything comes from where all
questions have answers in the form of no
questions at all where no Hearts break
because there are no Hearts to be broken
where no hopes can be crushed because
there is nothing to hope for and where
there is no loss because there is
nothing to attach to
Heaven Nirvana Moksha liberation
or you can continue on in the cycle and
return to where you were you won't know
any of this happened there will be no
lesson learned here for you to apply to
your next life you won't be who you were
you will be reborn as someone else
someone destined to all the same
features and experiences of corporeal
existence
so
what will it be
you stared at both openings as they
stared back at you
the eyes of being and non-being the
Absurd cycle of futile passions and
desires and experiences stood next to
the Eternal Bliss of nothingness you
looked at the figure then back at the
openings
in that moment in the face of
nothingness the pain of everythingness
felt comforting
if that's heaven give me hell
you said
you approached it
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by brilliant while
we are here wherever we are rules and
secrets of the universe appear to be
encrypted in mathematics and we appear
to have some built-in mechanism that
compels and allows us to decode these
Mysteries through science what is
infinity is it real how do various
forces and energy affect the everyday
happenings around us how do we make
decisions in the face of uncertainty
what will come of algorithms and AI you
can explore all of these topics and so
much more through fun interactive
courses on brilliant.org dive into
forever in brilliant's amazing course on
Infinity where through interactive
exercises and visualizations you'll
develop an intuitive understanding of
infinity how to count it theoretically
and how to Grapple with and appreciate
its paradoxical outcomes and geometric
beauty or in the course physics of the
everyday become an expert at
understanding the intricate nature of
how the physical world around you Works
day to day from how toilets flow to how
traffic doesn't to where celebratory
stray bullets Land by engaging in topics
like these contemplating paradoxes and
big ideas of the universe as well as
digging into how little things work down
here in the day-to-day you'll deepen
your appreciation for the marvels of the
big picture and the small challenge your
assumptions and beliefs and expand your
critical thinking and reasoning skills
in order to live well or simply ramp up
fast on subjects in areas that you're
looking to explore and make a career out
of no matter what your interests are or
reasons for achieving your goals in math
and science brilliant is a powerful
solution because it breaks Big Ideas
down into interactive building blocks
that makes the process fun rewarding and
effective for all Learners go to
brilliant.org pursuit of Wonder or click
the link in the description below to
receive a free 30-day trial the first
200 people will also receive 20 off
their annual premium membership
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]